[Musique]
angie franchement tu peux pas nous faire
un petit if avant de retrouver les
chevaliers du fiel a alors les
municipaux est-ce qu'on peut pas faire
ça tu nous fais vers 4-5 titres comme ça
on kiffe pour nous moi je kiffe qu'un
truc alors tu fais ou si vous finissez
par sa prestance et que j'occupe allez
tu peux nous faire quoi mukendi je sais
pas je vous laisse faire peut nous faire
mal en mi bémol on mimolette
quand j'ai froid je fais lumière gmail
se fit rien
à midi tout dans un silence en jeu sauf
rennes souvent avec moi quand je ris
elle rit aux éclats avec mon public
mes chansons sont souvent pour elle elle
sera toujours ma mère aig
quand je ne sais pas
[Musique]
à saint leu
ce sens
[Musique]
fois ci
non
[Applaudissements]
rentrée
le slogan el manzeh
déjà
je
et non sur l'amour retrouvé seul à la
barre est aussi une chanson que j'adore
williams et clément et clément lequel le
nom de grève ou non
yann
avant le duo avec gras dur il ya une
france et la chanson préférée de jean
michel maire
non mais il espère être moi ton privée
elle veut pas nous la faire
[Musique]
je sais pas ce que ça
non mais
[Musique]
m
ça
j'adore quand tu fais ça je comprends
jamais ce qui mit sa coiffe dit des
conneries c'est moi je le devais tony
dowe ça fait déjà plus d'une semaine que
je n'ai plus de tes nouvelles
oui ça chante comme ça gars sympa
montcalm si vous voulez faire les deux -
petit rosa cossart ça si tu es venu pour
me parler sur ce ton je préfère que tu
me dises tout de suite je suis pas ton
couteau vois tu as ont gradué un débat
c'est quoi le premier complexe c'est
mama c'est un hommage et à valence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
salazar
ça
[Applaudissements]
le bois dur c'est une gueule de radio
[Musique]
si tu as sauvé